oh hello there
reject nation happy Monday listen guys
the Maze Runner this part 3 movie I
didn't put up a reaction for it
yesterday because I had not seen the
Scorch Trials I have now seen the Scorch
Trials it is not better than the first
Maze Runner it's a lot of questions a
lot of questions with no answers yay I'm
hoping this one we finally get some
answers and I've grown to really
appreciate Dylan O'Brien so I'm actually
kind of looking forward to seeing this
trailer yay let's do this
[Music]
- know by this song yes yes I do
[Music]
and now we want a break looks like Mad
Max
[Music]
oh snap
where the hell is it stuff it stops when
we find a cure there is no cure
[Music]
it looks great
Thomas you can save your friends
or you can save us all
it's a January release Oh
January did the other ones come out in
January I don't think they did wonder if
they're not as confident and this
adaptation of the second one didn't
perform as well at the box office it's
like almost double the budget and
definitely didn't make as much money as
the first one for what I can tell about
this specific one I forget a lot of the
characters names all I remember is
Thomas because you know he's Thomas but
I do like about this trailer is that it
seems to have a different look it has
its own distinct look as compared to the
other two installments the set pieces
and the action sequences seem to really
be ramped up there's one thing that I
appreciate about the Maze Runner stories
is that they're really big on their
tension and their questions it's kind of
like a young adult version of lost for
me for me and servant aspects that
sequence with the train and the cars and
the guns and the way they're dressed is
really post apocalyptic vibe did seem a
little bit of fury road inspired I feel
like a turn there's gonna be some
apocalyptic cool cars and guns that
people are gonna immediately associate
with fury road and that's exactly what I
did right now the way this teaser is
being set up is don't you finally want
to have some answers yes that is exactly
where I'm at I would like to finally
have some answers on what's going on the
first one I thought was really damn good
actually the second one was yeah but
this one supposed to be the final one I
don't know if this is a two-parter this
might just be one movie I'm hoping
that's all it is it looks like we're
gonna finally get some answers I love
that in this post-apocalyptic world you
know Thomas Dylan O'Brien and the rest
of the gang still looks great you know I
just can't stand that in like
apocalyptic types of environments where
people just look so beautiful I'm like
you're like in the desert and I forget
the character's name but she's teased in
the end of the first Maze Runner you see
her kind of wherever you know little
fingers having a conversation with her
and the Scorch Trials but the woman at
the end who's telling Dylan O'Brien you
can save your friends or you can save us
all I'm excited that they're finally
gonna be able to meet each other because
every time we've seen her she's been on
the television or she's like that you
know phone hologram thing and now you
know they actually get to come
face-to-face with each other so
I am a looking forward to this I'm
excited to finally see some answers and
get some and get some solid conclusions
on this I have to avoid comment boxes on
this trailer because I know that this is
based on a book and people love to spoil
stuff but the first two Maze Runner
movies being September releases that
kind of shows the faith the studio had
in the films when in studio is push a
movie unless it's like blum house doing
a horror film they put it in January I
tend to get worried about what the film
is gonna be because January is usually
the month where Hollywood takes a dump
and they just like let's get our bad
movies out of the way in January for
20th Century Fox will be putting this
movie out in January has me a bit
concerned however the visuals I think
look like an improvement the action
sequences look really amped up I feel
like we're finally gonna get some
answers I'm at the point now where I'm
like I don't even care if the movie is
that good I just want to know what the
hell's really going I'll definitely
check it out because you know I've
invested this much time into it I might
as well find out the ending didn't do
that with the divergent series but I'll
do it with this one anyway guys are you
excited for Maze Runner the death cure
is Dylan love Brian your favorite actor
everyone loves that boy he is so
handsome and talented we're like the
same age dick away no he's a year young
as a year and a week younger than me I
hate him but I love him anyway guys
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell fall dad shot Humphrey
on Twitter and it's crap for no reason
check out our patreon become up a
charter check today